the fires have ripped through thousands
of hectares of forest
turning trees and farmland into ash
and they aren't done yet
extra firefighters have been called in
to help in the battle along this aegean
coast
the beast of a fire is now heading
towards holiday homes
and a nearby power plant which provides
electricity
to more than half a million people
they're working day and night to cut
scars in the forest
and create a fire break to slow the
flames down
bringing in heavy machinery to fell
trees and forge a path to save lives
homes and businesses
helicopters ferried buckets of ocean
water to dump on the flames
over and over again there's been a
visible increase in personnel here
as the fires rampaged through
local residents watched aghast at the
unfurling emergency
one week on they're still struggling to
contain the fires amid
some of the highest temperatures on
record and despite the constant ash
raining down
some tourists pressed on with their
holidays
a few hundred meters away on the hill
behind them the inferno was getting
dangerously close to holiday apartments
this is exactly what they've been trying
to prevent the strong winds and
scorching heat are proving a formidable
combination
the scale and strength of these
wildfires are staggering
and keep on getting the better of the
fire crews
it's quite normal well it's more it's
more extreme it's the worst in 40 years
climate is changing whether it's getting
hotter
and when you look behind you and you you
said it's under control do you think
that's under control
that's like a it has been on fire same
spot for two days
it's not moving anyway so we are not
bothered with it it's um well it's let's
say
like a you know watch fire it's not
going anywhere
but after a small lull despite their
confidence
just when the exhausted fire crews
thought they'd got it contained
sparks and strong winds set off the
fires again and the crews beat a very
quick retreat
they are proving no match for the
elements and the heatwave and low
humidity is set to continue all week
that's what the fire is left behind
trail
of devastation and the way they've tried
to stop it from
progressing is to build a breaker
they've cut a
a huge scar in this mountain forest
which leads all the way down there and
it's acted as a break
to try and stem the flames and save that
little holiday village which was
standing in the way of the fire
even after the fire passes the danger's
not over
there's so much heat around the flames
often reignite
so surviving foliage needs to be cut
and the embers have to be cooled
firefighters
even those with obvious wounds press on
there's too much to lose and too much to
do
i'm working non-stop day and night this
job is my heart
this is a traumatic time for turkey's
citizens
and there's a lot of fear as huge
sections of the country go up in smoke
and questions mount on just why the
fires have been so bad
and why the nation wasn't better
prepared for them alex crawford sky news
in southern turkey